>> IN LVIV, I'M GRIFF JENKINS.
NOW TO GO VEILED.
>> HEY THERE, MY FRIENDLY FRIDA
FRIEND.
HOW DO YOU KNOW WHEN YOU ARE
LIVING IN A DELUSION.
OTHER THAN JOE BIDEN THINKING --
WHEN PEOPLE SUDDENLY BELIEVE
SOMETHING IS HAPPENING, WHEN IT
REALLY IS NOT AND THEN THEY COM
AFTER YOU IF YOU REFUSE TO PLAY
ALONG.
THE LEFT OF THIS COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW IS LIKE THAT MENTALLY ILL
HOMELESS GUY SCREAMING AT
SOMEONE ON THE SIDELINES BUT
THERE'S ACTUALLY NOBODY THERE.
IF YOU TELL HIM NOBODY IS THERE
THEY WILL ATTACK YOU FOR
POINTING OUT THE SITUATION.
WITH OUR MEDIA SUCH SOLUTIONS
ARE REWARDED WITH ATTENTION AND
THEREFORE INCENTIVIZE.
THE LATEST DELUSION THE FLORIDA
PARENTAL RIGHTS BILL HAS BEEN A
ATTACK ON AND TRADESPEOPLE AND
SOMEHOW NEARLY STATING THAT
DISTINCTION BETWEEN A MALE AND
FEMALE IS AN AFFRONT TO THEM.
ACCORDING TO MY DATA 99.9% OF
AND TRANS ARE NOT OFFENDED BY
THE TERM BOYS AND GIRLS PREFER
THAT I GET THAT STATISTICS?
WHERE I GET ALL MY STATS, THE
STEAM ROOM.
BUT SADLY ALL YOU UNHINGED
VOICES IN CONTROL OF THE BLOW
HORN KAT, AND BY LAVARNWAY MEAN
MAINSTREAM THE MAINSTREAM AND
SOCIAL MEDIA, WHERE ATTENTION
STARVED ACTIVIST DEEMED WORTH
LIKE BOYS AND GIRLS HARMFUL.
THESE PEOPLE ARE FULL OF MORE
THAN AN OCCASIONAL OF JIM'S WIT
LACTOSE INTOLERANCE.
I KNOW THAT.
BUT LIKE THE BUBONIC PLAGUE, IT
IS A RODENT SPREADING THE
PROBLEM.
TAKE IT AWAY, HOMELESS MICKEY
MOUSE.
>> SUDDENLY THEY WERE MOVE.
ALL OF THAT GENDER GREETINGS --
SO WE NO LONGER SAY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AND BOYS AND GIRLS.
WE PROVIDE TRADING FOR ALL OF
OUR CAST MEMBERS AND THEY NOW
KNOW IT IS HELLO EVERYONE OR
HELLO FRIENDS.
IN THE PROCESS OF CHANGING OVER
THOSE RECORDED MESSAGES SO SOME
OF YOU ARE FAMILIAR WHEN WE
BROUGHT THE FIREWORK.
>> THE MAGIC KINGDOM, WE NO
LONGER SAY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
AND BOYS AND GIRLS.
WE SIT RUMORS OF ALL AGES.
>> THEY ONCE KNEW THE IMPORTANC
OF UNDERSTANDING YOUR AUDIENCE.
NOW THEY DON'T EVEN LIKE THEIR
AUDIENCE.
IT ALL SOUNDS LIKE THIS IS
WELCOMING EVERYONE BUT THE NO
GIRLS ALLOWED SIGN.
THAT THE CUSTOMERS ASK FOR A?
IS A CORPORATION TERRIFIED OF
BEING UNWOKE.
WHY, THEY ARE TO BE SEIZED
PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE FOR
THEIR KIDS AND MAYBE ONE WEEK A
YEAR TO TAKE THEM TO CURE THEME
PARK AND DROPPED COUPLE GRAND.
WATCH OUT, POLICE MANAGEMENT,
HAS BEEN ENTERTAINING FOR 99
YEARS BUT NOW THEY ARE SWITCHIN
TO GARBAGE.
IT'S HAPPENING AND GOVERNMENT
TOO.
PROBABLY FACE POSSIBLE WAR AND
SOARING INFLATION ABOUT WHAT IS
THE WHITE HOUSE CONCERNED ABOUT?
THEY OUT THAT US AIRPORT
SECURITY PROCEDURES WILL BECOME
GENDER-NEUTRAL.
THE GOING TO USE A X FOR
TRAVELERS THAT DON'T IDENTIFY A
MALE OR FEMALE.
BUT ISN'T X THE FEMALE
CHROMOSOME.
WAIT TILL THEY COMPLAIN ABOUT
THAT.
THEY WILL ALSO RECEIVE
INSTRUCTIONS TO MAKE PROCEDURES
LESS INVASIVE, WHICH IS SAD.
BEING MARRIED, I STARTED TO
ENJOY THOSE PAT DOWNS.
BUT, OF COURSE, BIDEN ALSO
CONDEMNS ANTI- TRANSGENDER
LEGISLATIVE A TAX WITHOUT CITIN
ACTUAL EVIDENCE.
>> YOU KNOW, IT IS HARD WHEN
THERE ARE THOSE AREN'T THERE WH
DON'T SEE YOU AND DON'T RESPECT
YOU.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE ONSLAUGHT OF
ANTI- TRANSGENDER STATE LAWS
ATTACKING YOU WHEN YOUR FAMILIE
ARE SIMPLY WRONG.
THIS A DEMONSTRATION IS STANDIN
UP BECAUSE ALL THESE HATEFUL
BILLS AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO
ADVANCING TRANSGENDER EQUALITY
IN THE CLASSROOM AND ON THE
PLAYING FIELD AT WORK AND OUR
MILITARY AND OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEMS, EVERYWHERE, SIMPLY
EVERYWHERE.
>> THIS RAISES THE QUESTION WHY
DID THAT WITH ONLY CONDEMNED
CRIMES THAT ARE HAPPENING IN
SEVERAL CRIMES THAT ARE.
ABOUT THE ATTACKS ON THE ELDERL
ASIANS OR THE RANDOM MURDERS BY
RANDOM MANIACS.
WHY DOESN'T JOE CARE ABOUT THAT.
COULD IT BE THAT THE PEOPLE
FEEDING HIM TO STOP DON'T CARE
EITHER?
IT'S SO WILL SMITH SLAP OF
POLITICS.
12 ARE TALKING ABOUT THIS, WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
NEEDING CRIB NOTES TO CLEAR WHY
HE'S TRYING TO START WORLD WAR
III.
LET'S FOCUS OUR ENERGY AND BUIL
UP FOR BIDS PEOPLE FROM TALKING
TO FIVE-YEAR-OLDS ABOUT WHEN WE
SHOULD BE ASKING WHY THEY ARE
FIGHTING TO KEEP INDOCTRINATION
WHEN THEY CAN EVEN TEACH MATH.
HOW TO DOES ANY ADULT WHO WANTS
TO TALK ABOUT SEXUAL ISSUES THA
THEY CAN COMPLEMENT IS THE ONLY
GOOD ARGUMENT FOR LEARNING.
SOLUTIONS BECOME DANGEROUS WHEN
YOU ARE PRESIDENT BUYS INTO IT
AND HE HAS.
HE'S OKAY ALSO BEING A VEHICLE
FOR IDIOCY.
AND FINALLY THERE IS THIS STORY
MEDICAL STUDENT AT THE PLAY FOR
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE PURPOSELY
MISSED UP HAITIAN'S MAY BECAUSE
HE GIGGLED AT THE STUDENT'S SHE/
HER GROWN-UP IN.
THE BRIGHT BUT A POSTING I HAD
PATIENT MY WAS DOING A BLOOD
DRAW SEE MY PRONOUN.
AND LOUDLY LAUGHED AT STAFF SHE/
HER, WELL, OF COURSE THAT IS
, WHAT OTHER PRONOUNS ARE
THERE.
IT?
SO I MISSED HIS VEINS SO HE HAD
TO GET STUCK TWICE.
WELL, SHE/HER THERE YOU GO,
CORPORATIONS AND GOVERNMENT
PEOPLE, ALL ACTING IRRATIONALLY
BASED ON THE BELIEF THAT THERE
IS AN EPIDEMIC OF HOSTILITY
TOWARD GAYS AND TRANS.
WHAT IS TRUE,.
THEY HAVE THE SCIENCE THAT
ACTIVISTS HAVE THE MEDIA.
>> LET'S WELCOME TO MY'S GUESTS.
>> WHEN SHE WAS BEHIND THE
PODIUM THEM MEDIA NEEDED IMODIUM
.
COHOST OF OUTNUMBER, KAYLEIGH M
cENANY.
>> HE'S SO FRESH THAT HIS BLOOD
TYPE IS EARL GREY PRETTY SO
BRITISH THAT HE SNEEZES CRUMPET
AND HE SO BRITISH HE SAID,
DOUBLE --
HE SO BRITISH THAT HE SHOWERS I
A RED VOTE.
PIERCE MORGAN, UNCENSORED.
>> THANK YOU.
>> AND SHE NEVER USES DRUGS AND
IS DELIGHTFUL TO WORK WITH.
APRIL FOOLS.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
AND HE WILL GIVE YOU THE SHIRT
OFF HIS BACK.
THE WORLD TELEVISION CHAMPION
TYRUS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Greg: SU ALMOST EVERY DAY.
YOU'VE BEEN IN MY DREAMS COME I
MY STUDIO.
>> I'VE BEEN BASKING IN THE
GUTFELD GLORY.
>> PART OF CABLE NEWS HISTORY.
>> YOU CAN JUST SAY THE HOUSE
PERSON AND BEAUTIFUL.
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ANTI- TRAN,
TRANS- PHOBIC, ANTI- GAY.
DOES THIS COME ACROSS AS A
MANUFACTURED OUTRAGE.
>> COMPLETELY.
IT'S A NEW VIRUS.
IT'S A VERY SMALL NUMBER OF
ANGRY UP AND DID CANCEL CULTURE
PROPAGANDISTS THAT TRY TO TURN
EVERYTHING INTO SOMETHING.
SO IF YOU TAKE ANY KIND OF
CONSTRUCTIVE CRITICAL APPROACH
THAT IS RIDICULOUS, IMMEDIATELY
YOU ARE BRANDED.
YOU ARE TRANS- PHOBIC,
HOMOPHOBIC, WHATEVER IT MAY BE.
I GOT PASSED OUT OF THE MORNING
SHOW IN UK BECAUSE MEGHAN MARKL
SPEED OF BUNCH OF LIES ABOUT OU
ROYAL FAMILY.
I SAID I DON'T BELIEVE YOU AND
WAS IMMEDIATELY ACCUSED OF BEIN
RACIST BECAUSE IT DIDN'T BELIEV
SOMEBODY THAT WAS BIRACIAL FOR
THIS IS THE WEIGHT OF THE WORLD
HAS GONE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS AND AWAY
FROM IT PERFECTLY ENCAPSULATES
HOW MAD IT IS ALL GONE.
YOU'VE GOT DISNEY, WHO WE KNOW
IS FREE WITH THEIR CONTENT WITH
COUNTRIES THAT HATE PEOPLE FOR
BEING GAY.
WE KNOW ABOUT THE CHINESE
OPPRESSION.
FOR APPARENTLY SUPPOSED TO
BELIEVE THAT THEY TAKEN A
POSITION, A STRONG POSITION
ABOUT THIS ISSUE DOWN AND
FLORIDA WHERE, MY GOD COMMIT IS
SO DESPICABLE, THE GOVERNOR IS
DECIDED THAT KIDS OF 5-6-7-8
SHOULD NOT BE EXPOSED TO
CONSTANT PROPAGANDA ABOUT THEIR
SEXUALITY OR GENDER AT A TIME
WHEN THERE ARE NOW 100 GENDERS,
INCLUDING APPARENTLY ASKED OR
GENDER, WHICH IS AFFINITY TO DO
THE STARS ON THE PLANET.
SO WHY WOULD ANY PARENT OBJECT
TO A TEACHER TEACHING THEM THAT
THEY CAN BE EXTRA GENDER.
YOU DID IT CAN RAISE THE IN
CRITICAL EYE OR A CONCERN BROW
AND SAY IT WITHOUT BEING BOUNCE
AROUND AND BEING CALLED A TRANS
PHOBIC, MOST PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE COMPASSIONATE PEOPLE
.
>> Greg: IT SEEMS LIKE THE
WOMEN ARE THE SPEAKING OF ALL
THESE THINGS BUT BUT I THOUGHT
THE GUYS THAT IT'S JUST THE
WOMEN.
>> THE WHOLE WORLD IS GOING
AFTER WOMEN.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
THAT IS HAPPENING.
YOU WENT THROUGH THE GOVERNMENT
AND THEIR CALLING PEOPLE
PREGNANT PERSONS.
LIKE ASE, I WAS A MENSTRUATING
PERSON, NOT A PREGNANT WOMAN
WHEN I CAME BACK --
BIRTH OF MY TWO-YEAR-OLD.
BUT IT'S CONFOUNDING.
THE HALF UP PREGNANT --
THERE A RACING WOMEN FROM
SOCIETY.
YOU ARE AN OPPONENT OF THIS.
BASICALLY WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
KINDERGARTEN GRADE AND FIRST
GRADE AND THIRD GREY CUP IS YOU
TEACHER WHO WAS BRAINWASHED BY
THE LEFT AND A LOT OF THEM ARE
TEACHES YOU ABOUT SEXUALITY.
NO THANK YOU.
AND HIS BANNED IS PRECEDENT THA
CAN'T KEEP HIS --
AND KEEPS TALKING ABOUT MY
FORMER BOSSES HIS PREDECESSOR.
HE NEEDS TO FOIL HIS A
MINISTRATION THAT'S COLLAPSING
SO LET'S GO AFTER KINDERGARTNERS
.
>> WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THIS,
TYRUS QUITE.
>> WE ARE MISSING ONE THING,
THAT SMALL GROUP, THEY ARE NOT
LIVING THE EXTERIOR AND THAT IS
WHY THEY --
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T FACT JACKET.
THE NOT GOING TO TAKE THE RISK
TO TALK ABOUT PEOPLE THAT ARE
ACTUALLY ASSAULTED BUT IT IS
ABOUT FUNDRAISING AND MAKING
MONEY.
AND IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
TRANSGENDER AT ALL.
IT'S JUST LIKE "BLACK LIVES
MATTER".
THEY WERE TRYING TO MAKE IT
SOUND LIKE THEY WERE THERE TO
HELP BLACK KIDS BUT THEY LINE
THEIR OWN POCKETBOOKS AND THEY
BOUGHT JETS AND PLAINS AND
HOUSES.
THEY WILL GO TO THE GROUP THAT
THEY LOVE TO HATE THE MOST
OPENLY IS A OLD WHITE BOTH MEN
AND WOMEN AND THEY WILL GO TELL
THEIR STORY AND FEEL TERRIBLE
AND BLAME THEMSELVES AND RAY
HUGE AMOUNTS OF CHECKS.
SO IT'S A MONEYMAKING SCHEME AN
SO THEY ARE NEVER GOING TO
ACTUALLY PICK UP REAL SITUATION
THAT PEOPLE CAN GO ACTUALLY
THERE IS MORE HATE CRIMES
AGAINST OLDER ASIAN WOMEN RIGHT
NOW THEN THERE IS THESE
TRANSGENDER THINGS HE TALKED A
BUS OF THE NOT GOING TO TOUCH
THAT BECAUSE YOU CAN ARGUE THAT.
SO THIS JUST DELAY UNTIL THEY
GET THE BIG MONEY AND YOU WILL
SEE THAT THEY ARE NOT HELPING
THE POOR TRANSGENDER IN THE
INNER-CITY HE WAS AFRAID COME
OUT.
THEY ARE NOT CONCERNED WITH THAT
.
BUT EVERYONE WHO IS DOING IT IS
IN A POWER-PLAY POSITION THAT I
WHAT THIS IS REALLY ABOUT.
>> Greg: KAT, WHAT IF THE
BATTERY STUDENT HER SIMPLY --
PURPOSELY MISSED THE BANE OF --
BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T LIKE YOUR
POLITICS AND SEBRING SHE'S IN
AND SHE PURPOSELY MISSES THE
MAIN.
>> HURTING CHEESE IS ONE THING.
I WOULD BE HERE.
I WOULD BE LAUNCHING A
FULL-SCALE ATTACK AGAINST THIS
PERSON.
OKAY, SOMEONE MAKE FUN OF YOU
AND SO YOU ARE GOING TO STAB
THEM BECAUSE IF YOU'RE MISSING
VEIN ON PURPOSE, THAT IS THAT
MISSING A VAIN, THAT IS STANDING
.
SO THE REASON YOU'RE DOING THAT
IS TO GIVE BLOOD OR WHATEVER,
SIDES WERE JUST DABBING THEM FO
NO REASON.
AND THINGS ARE SO CRAZY THAT SH
ACTUALLY WAS LIKE THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I CAN'T TWEET AN
PEOPLE WILL LIKE THAT.
LIKE I STEPPED THIS PERSON WHO
MADE FUN OF ME.
IT WASN'T EVEN A TRANS- WOMAN.
>> I BET SHE HAS HASHTAG BE KIN
AS A BIO.
>> PROBABLY.
>> HOW IS THAT NOT A HATE CRIME?
IF I STAB SOMEBODY UP WITH A HER
/HIS OR WHATEVER ON THEIR
THING AND I STABBED THEM, THAT
IS A HATE CRIME.
IT'S A TWO-WAY STREET.
>> PERCIVAL HE MISSED A VEIN IS
LOT MORE THAN YOU NEED.
>> SHE HAS ONE OF THE SIGNS AT
THE FRONT OF HER HOUSE THAT HAS
A LIST OF ALL THE THINGS AND
YOU'VE SEEN THEM EVERYWHERE BUT
I APPARENTLY SHE'S NOW BEEN
PUBLISHED THAT SHE'S NOT ALLOWE